FEMALE SPEAKER: Alyssa Goodman
is the Robert Wheeler Wilson
Professor of Applied
Astronomy a Harvard University
and a research associate of
the Smithsonian Institution.
Goodman's research
and teaching interests
span astronomy,
data visualization,
and online systems for
research in education.
We're really honored
to have Alyssa
talk about the WorldWide
Telescope Initiative
today at Harvard.
And without further ado,
I want to welcome Alyssa.
Thank you so much for joining.
ALYSSA GOODMAN: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
ALYSSA GOODMAN: I
don't need that, right?
Hi.
Well, welcome,
everybody who's here
and the many people
who I understand
can't walk in the rain.
California.
So anyway, you're
probably wondering
why there's a picture of
Chicago on the screen.
I'm curious.
Does anybody here
have any reason
why there's a picture of
Chicago on the screen?
OK.
So that means
probably none of you
were involved in the
meeting that gave birth
to WorldWide Telescope.
So before I continue, can I
just ask-- raise your hand
if you have an interest in
astronomy for some reason.
Just about everyone in the room.
OK.
Now I know why you came.
Raise your hand if
you work for Google.
Almost everyone.
OK.
Not quite.
And raise your hand if you're
interested in writing code
for open source projects?
A few of you.
Excellent.
OK, good.
All right.
My goal in this talk is to
explain the interesting history
of how this project known
as WorldWide Telescope
came to be and tell you
where I think it's heading.
And hopefully, many people here
at Google and around the world
are going to be inspired to
contribute to what is already
a very large project.
But the bottom line
is that this project
went open source
a few months ago
and is hopefully going to become
a very big worldwide effort
that will let the public share
in the joy that is astronomy.
So let me tell you very quickly
how I wound up standing here
and what WorldWide
Telescope has meant to me.
So the first picture
that you see here
on the left, this picture is
my friend and colleague Curtis
Wong.
And then this picture is me.
And we were at a meeting, the
first astronomy visualization
meaning that either Curtis
or I had ever gone to,
in Chicago in 2005.
And we were both sent
there by friends.
It was almost like being
fixed up on a blind date.
So we were sent
there by friends who
thought that we would both
enjoy a little respite
from our normal
meeting schedule.
And let's go this fun astronomy
visualization meeting.
Because I have interest
in both of those things,
but never in
specifically outreach
and that kind of
visualization in astronomy.
And Curtis Wong had
done a lot of work
using cutting edge
media to tell stories
about interesting subjects.
So he made an incredible
CD-ROM about Leonardo da Vinci
that some of you may have seen.
Another one about the
Barnes Foundation.
But anyway, he's all about
integrating audio, and video,
and data, and text, and
all kinds of information
in as seamless an environment
as you can possibly
offer for somebody to explore
and learn on their own.
So at this meeting,
I was talking
about a new project
we had started where
we were using medical
imaging software
on high dimensional
astronomy data.
And that's not something I'm
going to talk much about today.
Ask me afterwards if you
want to know more about it.
We're still doing it.
We have a new software
effort on that separate
from WorldWide
Telescope called GLUE.
That's a high dimensional
data visualization program.
But Curtis was talking
about this dream
that he had to take all this
astronomy data that was online
and make it available
to people as kind
of a substrate for a program
that would let you move
through the sky or
through the universe
and tell stories about
astronomy and about the universe
to each other.
And the idea was
that you would build
these tours of the universe
where an object in the sky
would be almost like a
weird little celestial
hyperlink, where you
could be at that object
and you could be
there because you
were trying to
learn about nebulae,
but somehow, something
about that object
would reveal that,
actually, it's
also in the catalogue of
somebody named Messier
and that this is
somehow important.
And you could learn about
the Messier catalogue.
When I show you the software
the now actually exists,
you'll see a little bit more
of what I'm talking about.
But basically, Curtis
described this dream
that he had that
wasn't yet a reality.
And I told him that
that sounded great
and that I would basically
help him if he ever did that.
And so, in the end, he did
get a chance to do that.
I'll tell you more
about that later.
And the software
was coded mostly
by one unbelievable
software architect
named Jonathan Fay, who I will
tell you more about later.
You're not going to
believe-- maybe you will--
but that this was made
mostly by one person.
Anyway, so in 2005,
this was just a dream.
By 2008-- and the
meeting was in Chicago.
And then a young
six-year-old in Chicago
used the software to make
a tour, which I'll show you
in a minute, one of these tours
inside WorldWide Telescope.
Tell us about what
he sees in Chicago.
And then by about
2010, the software
was so capable that it was
used by the Adler Planetarium
in Chicago to make a
completely digital planetarium
show for what turned out to
be about 1/10 the cost of what
a planetarium show
normally costs to produce.
And then, about a year
ago, it became clear
that it was going to be possible
to make WorldWide Telescope
open source.
I'll tell you more
about the details later.
But it had been seven
years since it started.
And Microsoft had spent
about $10 million.
I forgot to mention that Curtis
Wong and Jonathan Fay worked
at Microsoft Research.
And so this project,
which is now open source,
did start at Microsoft Research.
So yes, I feel honored
to be coming to Google
and telling you
about a project that
started at Microsoft Research
that you can participate in
if you'd like.
Anyway, so we had this meeting.
There's a series of meetings
in astronomy called .Astronomy,
which is for people who
are interested in using
the internet to both do
astronomy research and outreach
and also education.
And so at the annual
meeting last year,
which was oddly enough at the
Adler Planetarium in Chicago,
we made a video that
you can go watch
about how much everybody
loves WorldWide
Telescope to introduce
it to the world
as a project that was
about to go open source.
But what I want
to do is I think I
want to start by just showing
you one tour before I really
explain what the structure
of all of our efforts are.
And I promise I'll give you
a little bit of astronomy
and a little bit of politics and
where this stands as an effort.
But I'll try to
weave them together.
So here we go.
Let's look.
This is the program.
And I'm going to
show you lots of what
it can do as we go along.
I'm not going to try to
show all of it to you now.
OK.
So if I go here on the WorldWide
Telescope Ambassadors site
and I go to Tours,
then I should be
able to open all
these YouTube videos.
And we'll go down
to the Ring Nebula.
OK.
So I'll scroll through these,
and you can have some idea.
There are all these tours that
are featured on the Ambassador
site.
But one thing I
should explain is
that anybody can make a tour.
And then, you can share
it with other people.
You don't have to put
it on the website.
So let's just-- sorry.
This is what happens when
you try to search and talk
at the same time.
Let's see if we
go one more page,
I think it's
probably under "the."
[BEGIN VIDEO PLAYBAK]
-I am six years old,
and I live here.
Actually, I live over here
in a big city called Toronto.
On clear nights, when
I look up in the sky,
I see something like this.
The tour I want
to take you on is
of the Ring Nebula,
which Wikipedia,
the free encyclopedia,
also calls M57.
I don't know what
that means really,
but I think it's like
a jewel in the sky.
The Ring Nebula is in the
constellation of Lyra.
Lyra is also where the
brightest star in the sky is.
This star is called Vega.
The Ring Nebula is a little
ways away from Vega over here.
My dad says that he
doesn't think the Ring
Nebula is too far away.
I read that it's 2,300
light years away,
which seems like a very
long bike ride. [LAUGHTER]
This is not how I
see the Ring Nebula.
I see it like this.
The Ring Nebula was discovered
a long time ago by someone
in France.
This picture of the
nebula is beautiful.
It looks like a
precious blue gem
in the middle of some
red, orangey stuff that
looks like fire.
I read that's because
different gases give off
different colors.
You can see green,
yellow, red, and blue.
A nebula is what happens when
a star like our sun dies.
It lets out its remaining
energy and expands,
making lots of pretty
pieces that one day can
become planets.
I think it's neat that stars
can be so amazing for so long.
I wonder what Vega will
look like when it dies.
That's my tour.
I hope you liked it as
much as I liked making it.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
ALYSSA GOODMAN: OK.
So that is just a video.
But importantly, what I
was showing you over here
is the actual tour.
And I am sorry that we don't
have sound working completely
correctly because the tour
itself is interactive.
So if I hit play and then I
start going through the tour,
I just want you to see that
it's basically just this series
of slides up here at the top.
And at any point, I could just
stop the tour and move around.
So I could investigate
the surface of the Earth.
I could investigate the sky.
All right.
So anyway, the tour
is itself interactive.
And the video versions
are just to be
able to share the tours with
people in a very easy way.
But what we noticed
from the early tours
that people started to
create is that there
was this educational opportunity
because kids, in particular,
were willing to really put
themselves out there and say
things that they
might not be able to
or not be willing to say in
something like a PowerPoint
presentation or a poster that
is the standard kind of thing
that they do in astronomy
units in school.
And so if you listen
carefully-- many of you
said you know about astronomy.
If you listen to
what Benjamin says,
he says, some guy in
France, who's Messier.
And then he says, M87.
And he says, well, I don't
know what that means.
And I don't know
who this guy is.
And so what the role
of the ambassadors is,
is to sort of connect
that kind of information,
to tell him, yes, some
nebulae are when a star dies.
But other nebulae are
when stars are being born.
And so anyway, that
was the whole start
of our WorldWide Telescope
Ambassadors outreach program.
But what I can tell you today
is that WorldWide Telescope
is useful in many,
many more settings
besides public outreach.
So I'm going to give you a taste
of all of the different ways
that we've used it to date.
But because I don't have time to
demonstrate the entire program
for you, I'm just going to leave
this panel up for a second,
and go through it,
and tell you that you
can navigate the universe
in three dimensions.
And I do mean the universe.
You can go all the
way out to the edge
of the observable
universe back in time.
You can look at the Earth.
You can add data to
the Earth or the sky.
You saw before we started
that you can navigate around
on the surface of Mars.
And you can, importantly,
switch back and forth
between the
three-dimensional views
and two-dimensional views of
the universe to let people
know what various phenomena
look like on the sky.
So officially, the
title of this talk
is Open Source on
a Universal Scale.
And the idea is
that this program
has been downloaded as an
application something like 15
to 20 million times.
We lost count at one point.
And the number of online
users in just a web browser
is also extremely
difficult to count.
But it's in the many tens if not
hundreds of millions of uses.
So a lot of people
are using this
for a lot of different
purposes, but we still
think that much
more could be done.
So let me explain some
context by going back
to the history of
astronomy and tell you
where these kind of
virtual skies came from.
So if you think
about Stonehenge,
OK, that's where we get
the 3,500 years ago.
That was clearly
one of the earliest
astronomy observatories.
No telescopes.
And then this picture of
Ptolemy in Alexandria--
looks like he has a telescope.
But we should all remember
that Ptolemy was just
looking through a
tube and mapping out
the positions of stars and
that people started coming up
with theories for how
the heavens worked
at about that time.
Ptolemy was the one
with all the epicycles,
for those of you who
know what that is.
And then people built fancier
and fancier facilities
for observing the heavens.
But still no telescopes until
Galileo came along a little
over 400 years ago
at point a telescope,
which was then a new
gizmo, at the sky.
And he learned a lot of things.
You saw, at the beginning,
I was playing around
with the WorldWide
Telescope tour that
explains how important
Galileo's discovery of the moons
of Jupiter was to our
understanding of the Earth's
place and the Sun's place
in the solar system.
So again, then something
tremendously important
happened right around
the time of Galileo.
You have this shift in science
to a data-driven approach
where your theories have
to be actually verified
by observations.
And astronomy was a big
part of that transition.
And so if we skip way ahead
to the 1930s, the reason
that there's a picture
of a radio telescope
there is because that
was when people stopped
using optical wavelengths.
So the wavelengths we can see
with our eyes, how many people
think about astronomy, are
called optical wavelengths.
And so the first
foray out of that
was with radio
astronomy in the 1930s.
And a lot of that technology
was developed hand-in-hand
with radar.
That's where that came from.
OK.
So then, the next big milestone
was to leave the Earth.
OK.
So the first
space-based observatory
was NASA's Explorer 7.
So that was now 1959.
And then, something that is
most important here at Google,
comes the advent
of the internet.
And what's really interesting
to me is that the first thing
people thought about when they
thought about the internet
and astronomy was, wow, we
don't have go on observing
and stay up all night anymore.
We're going to build
these robotic telescopes,
and we don't have to
actually go there.
We can just have instruments
take data for us, which,
while a good idea and
important in astronomy today,
is not actually
the real potential
of the internet for astronomy.
The real potential
is in data sharing.
OK.
And in doing research using
vast, vast repositories now
of online data.
And someone asked a question
over the internet about-- I
think in the abstract
for this talk,
I mentioned that astronomy data
were economically valueless.
And that's why--
yes-- and that's
why a lot of computer
scientists love
to work with astronomers
because there's not
a lot of economic
politics that go along
with sharing data in astronomy.
And the person asking
the question online
did point out that,
yes, astronomy data
have been very important
in navigation and things
like that.
So indirectly, astronomy
has some economic value.
But most astronomy
data can be thought
of as valueless in an economic
way and very easy to share.
So anyway, that's
way astronomers
are often thought of as in
the forefront of data sharing.
I'll tell you a little bit more
about the politics of what all
those logos mean down there.
But let me just say that I
think that this dividing line
between pre-telescopic
and telescopic observing
is as important
as the opportunity
that we have now, where there's
all of this astronomy data
online.
And I think the way
that astronomy is done
has just completely changed.
And just for fun, I
thought I would give you
some idea of the financial
numbers involved.
So just before Galileo
and his telescope,
Tycho Brahe built two
observatories with money
from the King of Denmark.
And the cost of one
of these observatories
was said to be 1% of the gross
domestic product of Denmark.
OK.
And then, by the way, it was
kind of too windy at that one,
so they had to build
the second one.
And nobody talks about
how much that costs.
But anyway, so
then-- what is that?
That's 29 years later, Galileo
comes along and disrupts
this system and starts
using a telescope.
OK.
So now, how much did the
Keck Observatory cost?
So this is a big,
modern telescope,
the first of its kind in
terms of being really big,
expensive, 8-meter
class telescopes.
And that's I think the 0.00002%
of the GDP of the United
States.
And this is still considered
an extremely expensive project.
Well, all the modern things
are even more expensive.
Anyway, but just for reference,
if you add 29 years to that,
you would get 2024.
And I think that it will
be possible to essentially
have full sky virtual
astronomy at every wavelength
that we know about
by about 2024.
We almost have it now.
OK.
So the very best
data, the newest data,
data taken for special
purposes, they're not usually
immediately shared.
But almost everything
else actually is.
And so you should know,
if you don't already know,
that Google is actually
involved in this big project
called the LSST, the Large
Synoptic Survey Telescope,
that surveys the whole sky
essentially every three nights,
and can look for
time varying sources.
And all of this data is
just an absolute gold mine
for basically data mining
and trying to understand how
the universe changes with time.
But most astronomers
are not very well
equipped to deal with that
kind of big data science.
So there's a big
effort in astronomy
to try to bring the
techniques of data science
and visualization more
into the mainstream of how
people do science.
And WorldWide Telescope is a
little bit of a part of that.
What I won't talk
about very much today--
but if you're interested
in that aspect of changing
the culture and all these
other tools for data
sharing and data
visualization, go check out
our larger group effort, which
is called Seamless Astronomy.
And it has to do with bringing
data and literature together
into the hands of a
researcher without them
having to worry exactly
about where it came from.
But today, I'm going
to talk about what's
just in this little
shaky blue square, which
is these tools for
getting to the data
and looking at it in
the context of the sky.
So the name,
WorldWide Telescope,
comes from an article that was
written by Alec Szaley and Jim
Gray in 2001.
And I'll just read
the introduction here.
It says, "All astronomy
data and literature
will soon be online and
accessible via the internet.
The community is building
the Virtual Observatory,
an organization of
this worldwide data
into a coherent whole that
can be accessed by anyone
in any form from anywhere.
The resulting system
will dramatically
improve our ability to do
multi-spectral and temporal
studies that integrate data
from multiple instruments.
The Virtual
Observatory data also
provide a wonderful base
for teaching astronomy,
scientific discovery, and
computational science."
So there's the abstract of
my talk, but written in 2001.
Now, what's important
is-- how many people here
know what the Virtual
Observatory is,
what that means?
Yeah.
Just a few of the kind of
professional astronomer types.
And so there's a whole
political back story
that I'm not going to go into
except for the importance of it
toward data sharing
and the future.
And so the extremely short
summary of this story
is that in 2001, not only
was that article written,
but the Virtual
Observatory that they're
talking about in the article
was a government-sponsored NSF
program to try to build
the infrastructure
to make this vision possible.
And the reason
Jim Gray's picture
is on there is because
he's one of the co-authors
of this original article.
And he's one of the inspirations
for WorldWide Telescope
that I'll explain in a second.
OK.
So in 2002, many countries we're
trying to have these Virtual
Observatory efforts.
And so they joined together to
make a standards body basically
called the IVOA or the
International Virtual
Observatory Alliance.
And then in 2007,
two projects started.
One was called Google Sky.
And the other one was
called WorldWide Telescope.
So raise your hand if
you've used Google Sky.
Almost, but not
quite, everybody.
Raise your hand if you
worked on Google Sky.
No one.
OK.
So Google Sky is not
officially supported by Google
anymore as far as I know.
And I don't really want to
say this, but I have to.
So at one of these
meetings in Chicago,
the team from
Google Sky was there
and the team from WorldWide
Telescope was there.
And they basically-- Google
Sky conceded defeat by-- yes,
some Googlers are nodding for
those of you can't see them.
But anyway, by saying,
you guys built a Harley
and we built a chop shop.
So go have fun with your Harley.
And actually, what I'm going to
tell you at the end of the talk
today is that I think we should
turn a Harley into a chop shop
a little bit more.
So you'll see what happens.
But anyway, in 2007,
some of you may
remember Jim Gray was a
great database pioneer.
And he disappeared at sea.
And there was this worldwide
effort to find him.
And he was never found.
But as a tribute to
Jim Gray, Bill Gates
gave Curtis Wong
and Jonathan Fay
the permission to go ahead and
work very hard on this dream
of WorldWide Telescope.
So this is why Jim's
picture is on the slide.
And Google Sky came out first
because WorldWide Telescope
was very guarded.
And they didn't want
to release the software
before it was done.
But anyway, I used to have
to go around and explain
that WorldWide Telescope was
like Google Sky only better
and that even though
I'm a big Apple Machead,
I was working with
Microsoft because it
was this amazing stuff.
But I don't really have
to explain that anymore
because now it's an
open source project.
OK.
So then, the government effort
was not managed optimally.
And the project was
canceled in 2014
even though, actually,
much more money had
been awarded in the interim.
And that's why the
logo had changed.
But what's important is
that also in 2014 and then
ultimately 2015,
Microsoft Research
agreed to open source
WorldWide Telescope.
So that's why we have
the little GitHub thing.
So the two things that are going
are the standards, the IVOA,
and the software project
WorldWide Telescope.
So just for reference, this is
what Google Sky looks like now.
You can still try to use it on
the web, and it still works.
It just only does what it
did in, I believe, 2011.
And just for fun, I went and
looked up the Wikipedia page
for Google Sky to see if I could
figure out a little bit more
about the history
before coming here.
And I noticed this phrase,
which I and no one at Microsoft,
as far as I know, put
in the Wikipedia page.
You can go look at the history.
It says, "It's
facing competition
from Microsoft's
WorldWide Telescope."
And then I thought,
where did that come from?
So I clicked on the
little reference.
And it's this article it says,
Microsoft's online telescope
blasts Google out of the sky.
So you can understand how
odd I feel standing here.
But thank you, again,
[? Tory, ?] for inviting me.
All right.
So now, you're getting a
little bit-- let's get back
into the software and what
it can actually do and stop
talking about politics.
But for those of you who
didn't know the story,
I thought it was
important to tell you.
OK.
So let's talk about this.
So the last thing
before-- sorry.
I will tell you one
more thing, which
is just that you
can go to GitHub
and you can actually
get the code.
And I know some of
you are going to ask.
So it's at MIT open
source license.
And again, Microsoft was working
on this for about seven years
to the tune of
about $10 million.
And the really
important thing is
to give credit to the two
main people at Microsoft who
made this happen, who are
Jonathan Fay and Curtis Wong.
I'm just their pet
astronomer friend.
OK.
I've done a lot, but
not written any code.
So one of the things that fell
to me was when the software was
open sourced, there was a call
for interest and participation
that was issued by the
American Astronomical Society,
the main society in
astronomy in the US.
And I'll explain their role
a little bit more later.
But a lot of people
weren't familiar
in the professional community
with WorldWide Telescope even
in the academic
education community
because they thought it was
just this outreach tool.
And I've shown it to
you as an outreach tool.
But let me show you
some more about what
you would tell research
astronomers and educators
at a higher level, at
a university level,
for example, what they would
do with WorldWide Telescope.
So I'm just going to flip
through this pretty quickly.
You've seen a little
bit about what
the interface looks
like from me showing you
the program a minute ago.
But I'll show you
what you can do.
OK.
So one important point
that I made earlier
is that you can actually run
this program in a browser.
And so let me just go ahead
and do that for you now.
So if you go to the
WorldWide Telescope web page
and you just click on this thing
that says Run the Web Client,
here we are in
WorldWide Telescope.
I'll make the screen bigger.
And I personally work
on star formation.
And in star formation,
we're interested in the gas
and the dust that forms stars.
And so, I prefer to look
at the universe this way.
But some people
like to understand
what that dusty
orange glowy stuff is
in the context of the stars,
so I can set an optical image
as the background.
And then, I can set
that infrared image
as the foreground.
And I actually can just
then fade back and forth
between an optical and
infrared view of the sky.
And I could do that for
any set of all sky surveys.
And there are many that are
already in WorldWide Telescope.
So let me just leave us in
Orion there for a minute.
And I could bring up this
thing called the Finder Scope.
And so I can just click
anywhere in the sky.
And then, I can go here.
And I can ask for information.
And I could look up the
Orion Nebula on Wikipedia.
Or I could look up all the
professional publications
that have ever been written
about Orion on a data service.
A lot of this is in
the slides that I'm
going to show you, so
let me stop demoing.
I think I've made my point
that this runs on the web.
And let me tell you that
the creation of these tours
gets a lot more
sophisticated than what
you saw from the six-year-old,
even though we love
when six-year-olds make tours.
And so this is a
tour that I won't
show you the whole
thing of, but this
is sort of a little
insider view of what
it looks like to make a tour.
It's a tour about a very famous
astronomer who, unfortunately,
died an untimely death.
His name is John Huchra.
And Bob Kirshner and
some other people and I
made this tour as
a tribute to John.
And we used just
about every feature
that WorldWide Telescope
has in making this tour.
So there's 3D data.
There's 2D data.
There's links to literature.
All kinds of things.
And so I'm not going to take the
time to show that to you now,
but if you get interested in
this, go check out that tour.
And again, we did post
the tour to YouTube.
And the only sad thing about
posting a tour to YouTube
is that you lose this ability
to use it interactively.
So let me just take one
little jump out of here
again to show you what I mean.
So if I go back
here and I-- let's
just open a different tour.
So if I go here,
and I go to Tours,
and some of our favorites are
in this folder called Kiosk.
I go here to John
Huchra's Universe.
And I ask to play the tour.
You can kind of
almost hear the sound.
What I mean-- by the way, I can
skip like a slide at a time.
I'm just going to hit the
Forward button to sort of skip
through this tour.
But what I mean is, let's
say that I'm interested.
Oh, you know, wait a minute.
What is that galaxy?
I can just hit
Pause at any time.
And then, I can go explore the
universe while I'm in the tour.
And so at the bottom
of the screen,
you'll see these little
links come up to tell you
what else is in there.
And this is what I meant
about objects in the sky
becoming way-points the same
way links are in web pages.
So basically, you can think
of WorldWide Telescope
as a web browser for the
sky because I could go here.
And I could say, oh, actually,
I'm interested in that thing.
And it's going to tell
me about this galaxy.
And then, I'm going to zoom out.
And then, you can see the
context of other things.
And if there are
other tours that
cross through the
place I'm looking at,
those would also come up in
this preview at the bottom.
So it's bad for people with
a short attention span.
Just watch the tours on YouTube
if you have a short attention
span because otherwise,
you get constantly
distracted by what else is
available to you on the sky.
So we like to think of
these tours as guided paths
through the sky.
Then, this is something
that is really
interesting for the future.
So there's an API and
a software development
kit for WorldWide Telescope.
And it's all HTML5
and JavaScript.
And so this has been
used by some rather large
organizations.
This particular
example is from NASA.
And there was an
important mission
that released its
data recently called
Planck that was an all-sky
map at a relatively
long wavelength.
And this is just a
little demonstration
of what it looks like to use the
website that they built using
entirely WorldWide Telescope.
So the links on these
slides all work,
and I'll post the slides
so you can go check it out.
Now, I showed you a tiny
little bit of how this works.
This is just the finder
scope that you saw before.
And here, you can see that
when deal with the information,
ADS Articles is the
astronomy literature.
SIMBAD Data is all
of this online data.
And then Wikipedia is-- I think
you're familiar with Wikipedia.
So you can right-click
anywhere in the sky in the web
version or the Windows version
and get all the information
that we know about any
particular position in the sky,
which, actually, I find
probably the most mind blowing
feature of WorldWide Telescope.
But I'll show you more.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
ALYSSA GOODMAN: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Is it easy to
[INAUDIBLE] telescope?
Could I also put the links
on the Wikipedia page--
ALYSSA GOODMAN: Oh, yes.
Oh, please, give me a minute
and I'll show you one.
See, this is what's
going to happen.
It's the best laid plans.
But now, let's go see
if this still works.
This is living dangerously.
Here you go.
So here's one of my favorite
nebulae, the Iris Nebula,
which is NGC7023.
Here's a link that says see
NGC7023 in WorldWide Telescope.
And then, when the internet
speeds up just a little bit,
it'll open WorldWide
Telescope to NGC7023.
And do we have time to wait?
Sorry.
The faster the internet
connection you have,
the faster this goes.
So anyway.
Oh, there it is.
OK.
So we can just click on NGC7023,
and it'll take us there.
And then if you want
to see something
that's really like
bizarrely self-referential,
you can go here.
And you can say Research.
And you could say Information.
And you could look
it up on Wikipedia.
And you'd go back to
WorldWide Telescope.
So I think the answer
to your question is yes.
OK.
So indulge me with another demo.
This is another one of
our favorite projects.
And this one actually has,
I think, huge relevance
to Google's mapping efforts.
And I think that a similar
project to what's done here
could be done for the Earth.
I'm going to show you all
of the astronomy literature
on the sky.
But imagine, for example,
"The New York Times" articles
on the surface of the Earth.
So I could show you a movie.
But instead, I'm going to
show you the real thing.
So if I go to ADS-- this
is the worst acronym ever
by the way-- ADSASSS.org.
It's my fault, too.
So this is a project that we
have that's funded by NASA.
Because ADS is the literature
service for all of astronomy.
And we've been in the
vanguard for a long time
that all of the literature
has been online in astronomy
for a very long time.
And so there's more than
100 years of articles.
And there's an
organization in France
called CDS that tags
the objects that
are mentioned in the articles.
So you actually can associate
positions and articles,
sometimes many positions
mentioned in one article.
And obviously, many
articles about any position.
This weird map that you see--
this, again, is all HTML5--
is a super position here.
Let me put an optical
map in the background
so it's a little easier.
I'll make it just
a regular image.
So hopefully, you
recognize here's Orion.
OK.
So you recognize that.
Now, if I switch
the slider this way,
that is a map of the
article density on the sky.
So you can actually see Orion
in the density of articles.
And then, if you
actually want to know
what are those
articles, you could
show the individual sources.
And then, you could
click on one of them.
And then, eventually,
it'll bring up
a list of all of the papers
and all of the data associated
with that particular reference.
And that takes a second, so
how much patience do we have?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ALYSSA GOODMAN: Yeah.
OK I'll turn this off.
Now the other thing won't
come up because I moved,
but it works.
Anyway, so these weird
stripes are like giant surveys
of the sky that have been done.
And they're not actually
giant squares in the sky.
So anyway, it's very
interesting from a history
of science perspective.
You can filter by
different kinds of objects.
Here's just articles
about H2 regions.
And suddenly, those
big stripes go away.
And so you can actually use
this for science as well as
for the history of science.
But anyway, I think this
would be really interesting
as an Earth-based
project as well
with Earth-based resources.
And at the moment, I
think it would look better
in WorldWide Telescope than
it would in Google Maps.
So maybe we can have
some kind of meeting
of the minds about that.
This, by the way, this
little demo will show you.
We did a little cute trick
where we filtered articles that
mentioned Harvard authors
versus ones that didn't.
I'll skip that.
OK.
So this one is another one
of my personal favorites.
So this ADS All Sky
Survey has two more parts.
One is the heat map of
articles on the sky.
Another one is being
able to put images back
on the sky where they
go from the literature.
So raise your hand if you've
heard of astrometry.net.
OK.
So astrometry.net is
a miraculous service
that will look at
images and figure out
where they go on the sky without
any coordinate information.
Ask me later how it
works because it's
really interesting.
But right now, we
have some of this
implemented as a prototype
in the ADS All Sky Survey.
But for fun, I'm
going to just show you
an image on the web
being moved to Flickr.
So there is on Flickr.
And then what happens
is a little bot
crawls around on Flickr
and puts it where
it goes on WorldWide Telescope.
So if I click this, I think I
can demonstrate this to you.
So it brings the actual image.
The question you asked-- it
just takes you to the position.
This is actually
bringing the image
that you asked about to
the position where it goes.
So now, you can see
that that lines up
with the underlying
All Sky image.
But then, if I was
interested, for example,
in what does that look like in
the infrared in the background,
I could go over here.
And I could say, make
that the background.
And then, I would learn
something very interesting,
which is that those dark
regions are actually
bright regions in the infrared.
And again, I could do
all the right-clicking
and find out about
all the articles,
but I don't want
to take all day.
So let me continue.
OK.
The American
Astronomical Society,
why are they interested
in WorldWide Telescope?
Part of the reason is education
and outreach obviously.
But another part of the reason
that might not be so obvious
is that scholarly publishing is
in something of a crisis moment
right now.
People are saying, why don't
I just publish my article
on the web?
What's the value of
journals anymore?
Why am I paying all this money
for you to publish my article
and then charge me
money to read it later?
OK.
So that's a whole other scandal.
But my friend and
colleague Josh Peek and I
and a bunch of other people
wrote this little prototype
"Paper of the Future" last year.
And this is just
scrolling through it.
And if you go check
this out, you'll
see a lot of possible
technology, some of which
have definitely been adopted
already by the American
Astronomical Society where
data can be embedded in papers,
links to the Python code
is embedded in the paper,
interactive figures
are in the paper.
And, in particular, what
you just saw before,
this linking a figure out of the
paper into context on the sky
is now also possible
with WorldWide Telescope.
And so that's part of the reason
that the AAS is interested.
They have a separate
project through the press
that publishes their journals,
the Institute of Physics Press,
called Astronomy Image Explorer,
where the images are sucked out
of the papers.
Now some of them are just graphs
and tables or they're graphics.
But they're not actually
images of the sky.
But what we can do is we
can identify the ones that
are actually images
after you do a search
and then offer all of those to
be seen in context on the sky.
So this ADS All
Sky Survey is going
to probably become the AAS
All Sky Survey, the American
Astronomical Society.
OK.
So I mentioned a
little bit about K-12
in the beginning
with Benjamin's tour.
But let me just tell you
that this Ambassadors program
has had a lot of success.
And I could show you all
the education research data
or I could show you my personal
favorite quote from a kid who
actually said that
the software was--
and I do quote-- "cooler
than Call of Duty."
And then later, I will
show you-- hopefully
we'll have time-- a
very inspiring tour
about Pluto that was made
by two high school students.
And just to let you know that
the outreach side of WorldWide
Telescope is quite
a well developed
in terms of that it's now
funded in part by NSF,
and by NASA, and by the
Templeton Foundation.
And there are
various projects that
have to do with
letting kids think
about the likelihood
of life in the universe
and have them understand
multiple spatial scales.
And I know a lot of
you are interested
in outreach projects,
and I'd be happy to talk
more about that later.
And this is being used at
the college level as well.
Some labs are being replaced
or augmented by online labs.
And then, in graduate
education, we've
actually had graduate
students make
outreach modules
for undergraduates
to try to explain
difficult concepts.
So that's what this thing
on the upper left is.
We've also built interactive
touch screen kiosks
with graduate students.
Here's a graduate student at
the USA Science and Engineering
Festival where the WorldWide
Telescope booth is always
extremely popular.
Oh, yes.
I forgot to tell you that--
I feel like saying, but wait,
there's more.
WorldWide Telescope
also works in 3D.
And I didn't bring enough
3D glasses for everybody.
But I think I did bring enough
postcards for everybody.
So you can write to me
and ask for 3D glasses.
But anyway, yes, right.
And it also works with the
Kinect and Xbox controller.
And no, not Google
Glass or anything yet.
But we're talking
about HoloLens,
which is actually important.
I'll get back to that
in a little while.
I mentioned already the "Cosmic
Wonder" planetarium show
at the Adler Planetarium.
There are more of
those in development.
And I also mentioned that
there's this fancy video
that you can go watch to
see how inspired people
are about WorldWide Telescope.
But I'm going to
skip that for now.
And I promised in my
abstract to give you
three examples of
things that people
might want to do with
WorldWide Telescope,
So there's the Pluto tour.
There's the talk
I gave yesterday
at NASA Ames about
using WorldWide
Telescope and other software
to actually look at data
and understand the structure
of the Milky Way in new ways.
And then, there's even
really crazy things
like trying to understand
the large scale
structure of the universe in
the context of observations
and of new simulations.
So let's see.
You want to see what high school
students do with New Horizons
data and Pluto?
Yeah?
We have a lot of
yes on that one.
OK.
Let's do that.
So let's go back to
WorldWide Telescope here.
And let us--
AUDIENCE: How old is
this presentation?
ALYSSA GOODMAN:
Which presentation?
The one I'm going to show
you from New Horizons?
It's from August.
I'm sorry.
It's like really old.
OK.
So let's see.
Let's open that.
So I just open.
So again, opening these
tours is a little bit
like opening a
presentation file.
And you can email them
around to other people.
They're not that large unless
there's a lot of audio in it.
Because all of the data--
I'll get to that in a minute.
But they're all stored
in cloud services,
so there's not much on
your local computer.
Oh, we're not going
to be able to hear it.
Darn.
Let's see.
Apparently the people online
can hear better than we can,
so we can go watch
this on YouTube again.
AUDIENCE: I hear music.
ALYSSA GOODMAN: You hear music?
OK.
He'll start talking soon.
Oh, it's gotten better.
[BEGIN VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-New Horizons began its journey
off the coast of Florida
on a rocket called
Atlas 5, aiming
to reach the edge of the
solar system and beyond.
First stop, Jupiter.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
ALYSSA GOODMAN: OK.
So I'm going to skip
through it because I don't
want to take too much time.
But I'm going to go all the
way to the New Horizons data.
OK.
So they keep talking about going
past the orbit of other planets
et cetera, et cetera.
And then, finally,
they get-- OK,
so there's some old
images of Pluto.
[BEGIN VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Years after it first
took off, New Horizons
reached the goal its mission.
Awakened from its
deep sleep, it was
able to capture
many images of Pluto
and its moons, which are
being sent back to Earth
over the next 16 months.
Through a series of
detailed imagery,
New Horizons revealed the
existence of massive mountain
ranges in Pluto's heart,
which, at 3.3 kilometers high,
are comparable in size to
our own Rocky Mountains.
Impressive, considering--
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
ALYSSA GOODMAN: So
again, let me just
show you that this
is interactive.
Right?
So this is a tour,
but this is actually
an interactive view of the
data that have been added.
So there's slightly
better New Horizons data,
but they haven't been added yet.
And then, if you
want to say, you
know why is Pluto not a planet?
Right.
That was the
question I was asked.
So if you were an
ambassador in a classroom
and a kid asked
you that question,
you would just zoom out, or
easier, just go to the Sun.
And then you just tilt the
solar system down a little bit.
And then you say, where's Pluto?
You're like, oh,
Pluto's this crazy thing
on this highly tilted orbit very
far out in the solar system.
And then they're like, oh, you
know, I'm still not convinced.
And so then you say,
well, maybe you'd
like to see the rest of
all the crazy stuff that's
friends with Pluto.
And you can turn on all of
the asteroids and Kuiper Belt
objects that we know about.
And then, you can go really,
really detailed on them.
And you can say, well, how
about if I speed up time?
So here's real time, 10,
100, 1,000, 10,000, 100,000,
a million times.
Boy, this is really
taking a lot.
Oh, I had to go like
100 million times
to start seeing
those asteroids move.
But actually, then you can
see that Pluto is essentially
a Kuiper Belt object.
And so it's not like
the other planets.
And so kids are usually
pretty convinced
by that kind of argument.
And then in terms of what is
the true nature of the structure
of the Milky Way, I'm
going to refer you
to this website, which
is called wwtstories.
And one of the stories
is about this discovery
that we made a couple years
ago originally that's called
the Bones of the Milky Way.
And in there, is a video that
explains the whole story.
And since it takes
a few minutes,
and I want to get
to a little bit more
about the architecture
of the software,
I'm going to skip
that and just tell you
that this amazing
ability to look
at images in a very wide
context and modern images
all being in there already
as All Sky Survey really does
let you do real research science
as well as outreach science.
And I'm trying to
get to the point
where it actually shows
the overlay of data.
Here we go.
OK.
This is why I
shouldn't use video.
I should use interactive.
Well, thank you, YouTube.
You can go look
at this yourself.
Oh, there it is.
Just as I gave up.
So you see these
little blue dots?
Those are actual measurements
that have been made
and that have been added
to WorldWide Telescope.
Turns out that this very
interesting story, which
I told at one of
your Sci-Fu meetings,
for those of you who were
here, about how you can use
the fact that the Sun is not
in the plane of the Milky Way
to actually understand the
three-dimensional structure
of our galaxy.
But again, in the interest
of time, I skip that.
And instead, I'm
going to just show
you one more very zoomed out
feature of WorldWide Telescope.
But before I do
that, let me show
you a tiny bit of the most
modern simulation of structure
formation in the universe.
[BEGIN VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Pull the tightly woven dark
matter web into a looser
network--
ALYSSA GOODMAN: So
this is simulated.
--of giant galaxy clusters.
A big challenge, the team say,
was recreating the variety
of galaxies we observe.
The model's 40,000 galaxies
include this spiral one
like our Milky Way.
In fact, the simulation
produces a world
that's remarkably similar
to the real universe
as we see it through
our telescopes.
And because this simulation
matches our observations
so well, it gives us greater
confidence in our understanding
of the universe.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
ALYSSA GOODMAN: OK.
So what I haven't done for
you in WorldWide Telescope
is actually zoom
out all the way.
So let me show you what
happens if we do that.
So let's pause this
so that we don't
crush the GPU of my computer.
Let's do that.
OK.
And then, if I just
start zooming out-- let
me firstly make sure I have the
whole universe turned on here.
We want the microwave background
as well as everything else.
OK.
So if I zoom way, way,
way out-- and actually,
it's easier to do this
using the Xbox controller.
So if I just hold down the
zoom out trigger button,
you can see the
stars start to move.
And then eventually, I'll
get to a model of our galaxy.
And then, eventually, I'll
start getting to the Sloan
catalogue of external galaxies.
There's a lot of space between
our galaxy and the next galaxy.
And so here is-- I might turn
off the background there.
That's the cosmic microwave
background in the background.
It's hard to say that.
Say that 10 times fast.
OK.
So I'm going to turn that off.
And so you can
see-- hopefully, you
can see-- each one of those
little dots is a galaxy.
And if I wanted to,
I could choose one.
And I could just say,
could you please fly
to that particular galaxy?
And then, when I would
get to that galaxy,
I could actually find out all
the data in the Sloan catalogue
about that galaxy, again, with
the same kind of right-click
that I showed you before.
So I mentioned that--
yes, that is Malala.
So I mentioned that we're
interested in exploring
new ways to interact
with the data as well.
And so yes, an Xbox
controller is nice.
But it would be even better if
we could really use our hands
in a more literal way.
And so this already
works with the Kinect.
But the kind of mixed reality
devices like the HoloLens
and whatever's coming
next from Google
will be even more
interesting for interacting
with the large data sets.
And we're particularly
interested in that interaction
because of this other
software project
that I mentioned
before call GLUE, which
is a high dimensional data
visualization package that also
includes 3D volumetric data.
But importantly--
and so we want to be
able to do 3D selection
with our hands
if anybody's interested
in that problem.
But importantly, the way that
the API, the web-based API
for WorldWide
Telescope works now,
you can already connect it
to other software packages.
So this is just a little
demo of a Python program
which is this GLUE software
talking to WorldWide Telescope
and sharing data across
the two applications.
So this does have powerful
research applications as well
as those in outreach.
So to just summarize
what I've said
and then I'm going to close
with a little video about what
we might think is going
to happen in the future,
there's a bunch
of communities who
are interested in
using this software
and who are already using it.
So people in planetariums,
in the educational world
at all levels, certainly
outreach organizations,
researchers, and the one you
might not have thought of,
the publishing industry.
What are they doing?
They're making these tours.
They're making websites.
They're making YouTube videos.
And most of the resources
for that are cloud resources.
OK.
And the way that
they're doing it now,
you've seen that the desktop
version that I'm running here,
which is what's used
for tar authoring,
currently only runs in Windows.
That should change.
It's an open source project.
Hint.
OK.
And stuff plays back
on the web just fine.
And the interactivity of
looking stuff up on the web
is fine, too.
The reason that there's
a toaster on there
is because there's a special
algorithm called Toast, which
is a hierarchical image
tiling format that
actually works a lot
better than what's
in lot of other software.
And there's servers for
doing that Microsoft
has made available
and will continue
to make available for free.
Great noise.
And in terms of those other
operating systems that
are shown there, the web
versions of WorldWide Telescope
work fine on all those,
but there are not
native versions for
anything other than Windows.
And so you've already seen
the sort of sky, planet, 3D,
et cetera, and access to
data that WorldWide Telescope
offers.
And if I just rearrange
this into the kind
of org chart of resources
that is in the proposal that's
going to the American
Astronomical Society,
you can kind of see how
this all fits together.
For those of you who
really interested
in this, what this
is basically saying
is that there's a bunch of
assets that have already
been assembled by Microsoft
Research and the other people
who've been working on
WorldWide Telescope,
then a bunch of tools for
dealing with those assets,
and many different end
user modalities for how
to get to those resources.
But again, this is what's most
developed over here, the web
client and Windows.
And this is what most
needs developing over
on the other side.
OK.
So where might Google
come into this story?
This is an actually real chart
now of all of the organizations
that are participating
in this effort already.
And it's a rather complicated
consortium set up.
Because right now,
the institutional home
for WorldWide Telescope
is not completely clear.
OK.
I mentioned that
it's being discussed
at the American Astronomical
Society will take this on.
There's a vote on January 4.
And so you will see news
if this vote goes well.
I give it pretty good odds.
OK.
But once this project
has an institutional home
with some full time
people committed to it,
it'll be easier to marshal all
of these other organizations
that are already participating
both in terms of staff time
and financially.
And so I just put a
bunch of Google on here
in all the places
where I think Google--
and in particular, down here,
the open source development
being one of the most important
aspects of the project where
Googlers could
participate as well.
And I'm going to stick
around this afternoon.
And anybody who wants to join
these conversations about how
we could make that
all happen, please do.
But I want to--
before I go here,
does anybody know this
person on the screen?
OK.
So this guy's name is Gonzo.
And he's a friend of
Chris DiBona's apparently.
And what I'd like to do
is just for a minute not
talk over him and let you
hear what he's saying.
Because he made this point
at a meeting a few weeks ago
of the consortium
about what he thinks
WorldWide Telescope should
become in the future.
And many of us think he's right.
And so I'm just going to let
him make that point for himself.
And then, I'm going to end
and take your questions.
Here we go.
[BEGIN VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-At some point,
you're going to have
to make some decisions
about how to evolve
beyond this two-client model.
And you have a
number of options.
But the one that I think makes
the most sense is probably
to stop trying to shove
everything into one interface,
but instead, turn the
WorldWide Telescope
project into a platform
and a framework
for services built on a
dataset and to run applications
small, perhaps overlapping,
but targeted applications
for each set of functionality
that you want to do
and perhaps for each community
you want to approach.
And start thinking
about engineering
to your next phase,
which is going
to be some sort of apps model.
And then that also
gets multi-platform
because you can have different
apps targeted for the platforms
where the communities are
for the people who actually
need to use them.
-So use the data infrastructure.
Use some of the
API and build apps?
-Right.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
ALYSSA GOODMAN: OK.
So I think he's
actually probably right.
And so what I wanted to
offer in the last few minutes
is I'll just tell
you that there are
a bunch of projects that
are going on right now,
only some of which
I've mentioned.
OK.
So I mentioned
Thinkspace and Life
in the Universe,
which are the projects
through the ambassadors.
I didn't tell you that there's
a third piece of the ADS All Sky
Survey where images
that can't be solved
through that automated
mechanism are actually
being solved in a citizen
science project, where people
are shown images and
asked to add metadata.
Some of those people are
high school students.
And that project is being
done through the Zooniverse
collaboration based in Chicago.
We're also using
WorldWide Telescope
in a very big online course that
I'm working on at HarvardX call
Prediction X. We're
using it to explain
both Earth-based and space-based
phenomena having to do with,
for example, people charting
their course across the ocean
using the stars.
So you can use it in odd
circumstances like that.
At lunch, we were talking
about this proposed project
that a friend of
mine, Eli Bressert
has called Raspberry
Sky, where you
use Raspberry Pis and
cheap little cameras
and observe the
whole sky every night
and look for things
that change in time,
and put data in a WorldWide
Telescope custom API interface,
just like what Gonzo
was talking about.
And so the last little
block is for you.
This is your scheme here.
And I think [? Tory ?]
and I are hoping
that people have some
interesting ideas
to propose from within Google.
And I have to say, the sound
effects are really excellent.
AUDIENCE: They're
reconstructing--
ALYSSA GOODMAN: OK.
Great.
So if you go to the
WorldWide Telescope website,
you can see the
overview of the SDK
that's already there if you're
interested in actually starting
to develop things.
So anyway, thanks very much.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
being able to take
a picture of the sky and
finding where in the sky it is.
How do you do that?
ALYSSA GOODMAN: Oh, yes.
OK.
So that's this
astrometry.net program.
And there used to be these
sort of brute force algorithms
that would actually just
look for things at known
positional orientations.
But the way this actually works
now is groups of four stars
that they call quads
are identified.
And then, they look
for the-- if you
draw an X or a twisted
X between those,
then the length of those
lines and the angle
between those lines is a
very unique fingerprint
if you have a bunch of
those quads in an image.
And so it's compared against
a catalogue of the sky.
And it's remarkably fast.
By the way, it's
being used also--
this thing called
DASCH, which stands
for Digital Access to a
Sky Century at Harvard.
So we own 600,000 glass
plate images of the sky.
It's the largest
collection of images.
It goes back 100 years.
And so that
astrometry.net program
is actually also be used to
solve for the coordinates
of these historical plates.
And hopefully, we'll wind
up with all those data
in WorldWide Telescope as well.
And by the way, you can't
get 100 years of time series
without waiting 100 years.
So even in the data that are
kind of crappy and very old
are incredibly valuable.
Because even if you have LLST,
to get 100 year time baseline,
you have to wait 100 years.
AUDIENCE: For people
who would like
to be involved, both Googlers
and the greater world,
how do you become involved
with the WorldWide Telescope
initiative.
And what opportunities
are available?
ALYSSA GOODMAN: Thanks.
So there's a lot
of opportunities.
So there's a GitHub page
that has all the code on it.
And there's active discussion
through the GitHub page.
But also, you can just go to
the main WorldWide Telescope
website or wwtambassadors.org.
And you can find all kinds
of contact information.
And basically, if you email
anybody in the organization
with any kind of volunteering,
you will be volunteered.
AUDIENCE: And it's not
bound to Massachusetts?
It can be really anywhere.
ALYSSA GOODMAN: Oh, not at all.
Not Harvard either.
You were very kind
in the introduction.
And while we do a lot
of this at Harvard,
this is not connected
to Harvard other
than that the Ambassadors
program is run from Harvard
and it's part of
Seamless Astronomy, which
is also run from Harvard.
But no, there's people
actually all over the world,
including-- apparently
WorldWide Telescope
is quite big in China.
So you can run this
program-- I forgot
to mention-- in many different
languages, including Chinese.
AUDIENCE: Well, thank you
so much again, Alyssa.
We really appreciate it.
And we look forward
to learning more.
ALYSSA GOODMAN: Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]